auch bei der hd brennt es gerade nach
vorwürfen von vetternwirtschaft filz und
geldverschwendung musste die ard
vorsitzende patricia schlesinger
zurücktreten sie ist zugleich
intendantin des rundfunks berlin
brandenburg rbb er diesen posten
klammert sie sich noch weiter deshalb
kann man wohl davon ausgehen dass ihr
rücktritt weniger aus eigener einsicht
als vielmehr auf drängen der anderen ard
intendanten zustande kamen die das feuer
ersticken wollen dann wird es nicht auch
auf ihre häuser übergreift die frage ist
allerdings ob es wie im grunewald
womöglich unlösbar ist weil sich über
die jahre einfach zu viel sprengstoff
angesammelt hat
vetternwirtschaft korruption und
intransparenz hinter den mauern des rbb
sendezentrums darin verstrickt die
chefin höchstpersönlich
patricia schlesinger
[Musik]
das sind dieser schwerwiegenden vorwürfe
gegen die rbb chefin so soll sie
abendessen mit gästen
privatwohnung veranstaltet haben diese
als dienstliche treffen deklariert und
unsauber gerechnet zudem soll sich
schlesinger einen dienstwagen mit
massage sitz gegenwert
145.000
luxuriös musste es nicht mehr in ihrem
auto sondern auch in der küche auf der
toilette ihres büros zu gehen insider
berichten von einer küche für 60.000
euro einer wie dieser der rbb flurfunk
lästert schon lange über hochwertige
rote italienische waschbecken in den
waschräumen von frau schlesinger ähnlich
wie diese und dann berichtet das
handelsblatt noch darüber dass sich die
geschäftsleitung des rbb 2021 angeblich
einem extra jahresbonus zahlen d es in
beträchtlicher aber bisher unbekannter
höhe deshalb nun der rücktritt als ard
vorsitzende jetzt soll der frühere ard
chef tom buhrow vorübergehend in den
chefsessel zurückkehren und wie geht es
beim rbb weiter schlesinger will als
intendantin chefin des senders bleiben
ein unding sagt christoph ploß
vorsitzender der cdu hamburg ich erwarte
dass frau schlese ja so schnell wie
möglich zu den vorwürfen stellung nimmt
und dass auch die öffentlich rechtlichen
auf volle transparenz drehen und so
sieht es auch cdu generalsekretär mario
czaja wenn frau schlesinger wegen
solcher schwere vorwürfe den
ehrenamtlichen ard vorsitz abgibt muss
sie auch vom hochdotierten posten als
rbb-intendantin zurücktreten
bisher hat patricia schlesinger sehr
wenig zur aufklärung der affäre
beigetragen
aufklärung ist jetzt aber höchste
priorität mit dem öffentlich rechtlichen
rundfunk system nicht der zuschauer
stellt sich die frage ob wirkliche
aufklärung mit schlesinger ezb
möglich ist
tja ich frage stellt sich in italiens wo
ihr bild chefredakteur ist bei uns im
studio mit welcher logik fragt man sich
wenn sie als ard-vorsitzende zurücktritt
kann sie rbb-intendantin bleiben guten
abend thomas die antwort ist ganz
einfach nein kann sie nicht denn sie ist
jetzt von ihrem ehrenamtlichen posten
zurückgetreten dass es ein posten der
turnusmäßig vergeben wird unter allen
chefs der ard sendeanstalten von denen
es ja mehrere gibt rbb ndr wdr br und so
weiter und die geben diesen aller dem
posten turnusmäßig immer weiter davon
ist sie zurückgetreten wovon sie nicht
zurückgetreten ist ist sozusagen ihr
hauptjob chefin des rbb der öffentlich
rechtlichen anstalt in berlin und
brandenburg dort hat sie allerdings die
ganzen skandale verursacht und deswegen
ist das nicht ausreichend dass sie nur
vom ehrenamt zurückgetreten essen sie
ist übrigens auch nicht zurückgetreten
von ihrer position als
aufsichtsratsvorsitzender
der degeto das ist die wichtigste größte
ard tochter über die sozusagen der ganze
tv serien und filme ganze fiktionale
marke eingekauften abgedeckt wird ja und
das ist natürlich auch bemerkenswert
denn aufsichtsrat das ist ja das
kontrollgremium und es zeigt übrigens
auch sehr genau wie die einzelnen ard
gewerke die ard ist ja riesenhaft ja
untereinander verbunden verknüpft sehen
was für eine vetternwirtschaft dort
herrscht dann kontrolliert sich ein
stück weit selbst da ist überhaupt keine
transparenz und transparenz möchte frau
schlesinger jetzt auch im moment gerade
bei den vorwürfen die sie treffen
vermeiden also das passt alles gut
zusammen und das ist ein armutszeugnis
für die alte kritiker sagen
frau schlesinger stehe quasi als person
mit ihrem verhalten im grunde für das
ganze system der ard teuer
verschwenderisch
intransparent selbstherrlich und
weltfremd wir schon mal ein paar
beispiele dafür
manipulative berichterstattung überhöhte
personalkosten geschmacklosigkeiten und
auch journalistisches versagen der
öffentlich rechtliche rundfunk steht
massiv in der kritik der gebührenzahler
politiker und experten wir zeigen
beispiele eine kleine auswahl
tendenziöse berichterstattung in
mehreren städten deutschlands zogen
mitte mai 2021 tausende demonstranten
durch die innenstädte forderten die
vernichtung israels brüllten
judenfeindliche parolen bedrohten
journalisten und gegendemonstranten die
tagesschau berichtet doch dieser
judenhass kommt nicht vor schwer wiegt
auch der fall der moderatorin enie el
hassan sie sollte
2021 die wdr wissenschaftssendung quarks
moderieren doch el hassan hatte an
mehreren demonstrationen gegen israel
teilgenommen bei denen es zu
hasserfüllten ausschreitungen gekommen
war erst nach medialem druck
distanzierte sich der wdr und beendete
im november 2021 die zusammenarbeit
nächstes beispiel
manipulation das zdf macht regelmäßig
den wasserdampf der aus atomkraftwerken
austritt zu dunklen rauch
psychologischer effekt kernkraft ist
schlecht der mdr löscht sogar ein bild
logo vom mikrofon der sender
entschuldigt sich jedoch später auch dem
sport journalismus urgestein und
ehemaligem ard sportmoderator waldemar
hartmann fällt die politische
einseitigkeit negativ auf nach außen hin
ist aus meiner sicht die balance
vergangen die politische mann aus ich
habe manchmal den eindruck dass nur noch
eine grün rote welle durch alle
informationssendungen geht durch alle
politischen sendungen geht auch durch
die talksendungen das kann für die leute
nicht die informationsquelle sein auch
beim thema ländern sind die
öffentlich-rechtlichen ganz vorne mit
dabei ganz anders als die mehrheit der
deutschen gern gebührenzahler also ich
halte es für ein unding dass
öffentlich-rechtliche die einen
bildungsauftrag haben in so wahrnehmen
dass sich die deutsche sprache die
strafe von goethe und schiller bilden
wohl nicht die leute bild nicht wollen
und informieren es gibt keine
gesetzliche grundlage es gibt keinen
auftrag das plötzlich die
öffentlich-rechtlichen anfangen damit
dass in die öffentlichkeit zu tragen was
sich ein paar menschen hauptsächlich an
der humboldt universität in berlin
ausgedacht haben auch braunbären werden
offenbar an das eigene weltbild
angepasst in einem instagram post des
online-netzwerkes funk betrieben von ard
und zdf bezeichnete der kanal braunbären
als veganer innen der gender doppelpunkt
wird verwendet damit neben frauen und
männern auch alle anderen geschlechter
einbezogen werden in diesem fall also
auch vegane transsexuelle nicht binäre
braunbären
geschmacklosigkeiten nur ein beispiel
aus dem wort fidget spinner einem
äußerst beliebten anti stress spielzeug
machte man das wort mit spina mit ist
englisch und bedeutet kleinwüchsiger
oder gar zwerg ein geschmackloses video
auf kosten kleinwüchsiger menschen gibt
es on top
verschwendung
185 millionen euro der rbb neubau kostet
plötzlich drei mal so viel wie geplant
warum wird er so teuer und warum braucht
man denn allein das haus des rundfunks
in berlin hat bereits 22 1400
quadratmeter bürofläche und in potsdam
gleich nebenan einen weiteren großen
standort man werde erst im sommer 2023
konkrete baukosten haben so ein sprecher
übrigens liegen die tv gebühren im jahr
bei über acht milliarden euro ard
entente an tom buhrow verdient über
400.000 euro das ist mehr als der
bundeskanzler
alle reden sie vom sparen also es
passieren dass dinge da würde die
sendung panorama daraus schließe ich
weiß das denn überhaupt fünf jahre sagt
reporterin fünf minuten machen und mit
den fingern auf die zeigen die das
veranstalten und
zerbrechen muss man fast sagen es ist
eine üppige geldausgaben maschinerie
aber jeden tag höre ich will sparen wir
sparen wir sparen thema sportrecht in
der beitragsperiode von 2017 bis 2020
haben ard und zdf insgesamt 1,2
milliarden euro dafür ausgegeben geld
der gebührenzahler
dabei können dass die privaten sender
genauso gut und refinanzieren sich aber
über werbung es gibt gesetzliche
grundlage das spiele der deutschen
mannschaft und die finalspiele im
öffentlich rechtlichen fernsehen so wird
das interpretiert von den
öffentlich-rechtlichen stattfinden
sollen im free tv
aber free tv ist auch bei rtl bei
bild tv oder bei sat1 meinetwegen jeden
fußballfan den ich befragt habe dem ist
das im prinzip scheißegal der muss
wissen wo der knopf ist wo sehe ich das
spiel kategorie außer kontrolle außer
kontrolle geraten ard und co wenn jemand
die gebühren nicht mehr zahlen will oder
kann die faz berichtet über den fall
eines studenten dessen einkünfte
unterhalb der sozialhilfe erstellt beim
beitrag service einen härtefallantrag
will von den zahlungen befreit werden
zurecht doch die öffentlich-rechtlichen
stellen sich quer sie wollen geld von
dem studenten
zu guter letzt journalistisches versagen
international beachtet paul ronzheimer
berichterstattung aus brutscher der bild
vize hat die russischen kriegsverbrechen
dort als einer der ersten gezeigt dass
gelang der ard nicht stattdessen
behauptete wdr journalist georg reste in
der tagesschau einfach journalisten
hätten keinen zutritt zu der
ukrainischen massaker statt butter
gehabt
[Musik]
also einige beispiele man könnte
natürlich auch noch mehr finden sein
fazit
er ist zeigt sich doch sehr deutlich
thomas dass die ard an der spitze ein
problem hat das frau schlesinger und
dann aber auch die kolleginnen und
kollegen haben es gerade in ihrem
beitrag gezeigt durch alle einzelnen
gewerke diese riesigen maschinerie
hindurch weitere probleme hat drastische
probleme es geht um die qualität des
produktes das oft mehr erzielt als
bildet es geht um den umgang mit den
zwangsgebühren die ja jeder deutsche
bezahlen muss aber will oder nicht die
verschwendet werden den platz bauten
luxus angelegenheiten und eben nicht
unbedingt dem programm zu gute kommen
und es geht um eine allgemeine
verkrustung und verlangsamung der
gesamten anstalt die dazu führt dass bei
den deutschen gar nicht die qualität
ankommt die sie eigentlich vom teuersten
rundfunksystem der welt und vom größten
in einem verhältnismäßig kleinen land
erwarten könnten
8,5 milliarden euro stehen den
öffentlich-rechtlichen zur verfügung
über die gebühren 5,9 millionen 5,9
milliarden bekommt die ard der
rundfunkbeitrag aktuell bei 18 eur 36
der fernsehdirektor des wdr jörg
schönenborn den einen demokratie beitrag
bedeutet im umkehrschluss ohne die ard
ist die demokratie gefährdet thomas ganz
ehrlich das ist eine bizarre
wortschöpfung ich meine fast muss man
jörg schönenborn dafür respekt zollen
dass er auf die idee gekommen ist aber
dann vermute ich ehrlich gesagt auch er
ist dann nicht alleine drauf gekommen
vor ein paar jahren hat die ard einer
sprachforscherin elisabeth wehling kennt
man nicht aber der name ist mittlerweile
jetzt bekannt ja einen auftrag gegeben
und dieser auftrag war ein frame im
manual also ein handbuch wie man sprache
so verändern kann dass die leute
manipuliert werden dass sollte frau
wehling erstellen und das hat sie auch
gemacht und das hat dann jemand
veröffentlicht heimlich das sollte
natürlich geheim bleiben in der ard und
da ging es eben schön darum dass man
nicht mehr sagen soll die leute bezahlen
den rundfunkbeitrag sondern sie
ermöglichen den rundfunk also eine
ständige schönfärberei schönrederei der
eigentlichen verhältnisse und ich sag
mal so wenn die ard so jemanden anstellt
und so jemanden beauftragt die sprache
über die ard bewusst zu manipulieren
dann wundert mich auch überhaupt nicht
dass jörg schönenborn auf den begriff
demokratie abgabe kommt wie allerdings
bild morgen zeigt wir haben eine tolle
umfrage gemacht möchten 84 prozent der
deutschen keinen beitrag mehr bezahlen
und das bedeutet natürlich auch im
umkehrschluss dass die sich von so einem
wort wie demokratie abgabe wie jörg
schönenborn ist jetzt verwendet hat
thomas davon fühlen sich glaube ich die
allermeisten deutschen einfach nur an
der nase herumgeführt nun könnte man
natürlich uns vor halten wir kritisieren
die öffentlich rechtlichen sender jetzt
scharf
weil sie natürlich auch unsere
konkurrenten sind
natürlich das argument sehe ich auch
schon kommen thomas aber es ist doch
ganz einfach ja viele leute schalten
bild tv ein viele leute lesen die bild
-zeitung viele leute sind auf bild
online aber kein einziger keine einzige
person da draußen wird dazu gezwungen
für unsere produkte zu bezahlen ohne sie
anzuschauen ohne einzuschalten ohne sie
haben chaos zu erwerben ohne ein abo
abzuschließen und das ist doch der
entscheidende unterschied mir wäre die
ard vollkommen egal die ard könnte
machen tun und lassen was sie wollte man
würde gelegentlich mal sagen das fand
ich gut das fand ich nicht so gut aber
wir würden es niemals so drastisch
kritisieren wenn es nicht die
zwangsgebühren werden johannesburg dank
für den besuch im studio nicht dank dir
[Musik]